Let's talk about religion this week.
Whether you're a believer or a non-believer,
religion has, and probably always will, play
some role in society.
This is why religion has been at least a part
of so many of the discussions I've had on
this show, from interviews with an atheist
like Sam Harris, to a Catholic like Bishop
Barron, to a christian Dinesh D'Souza, to
orthodox Jew like Ben Shapiro, to ex-muslim
Yasmine Mohammed to atheist Muslim Ali Rizvi,
to Jew turned atheist turned Christian like
Andrew Klavan, and so on.
All of these religious descriptors exist for
each of these individual people, no matter
how confusing they might be to anyone from
the outside looking in.
I for one, have consistently enjoyed talking
to people from all walks of life and seeing
what they believe and how they took, or did
not take, the leap of faith to get where they
are in their spiritual journey.
As I've said many times before, I am NOT a
believer, but I don't really care whatever
anyone else believes, as long as their religious
beliefs don't take the form of legislating
my life.
In the privacy of your home, you can believe
in Yaweh or Jesus or Mohammed or the flying
Spaghetti Monster and that's none of my business.
If your religious beliefs give you some sense
of purpose or inner piece then great, it's
when your belief bleeds into who I can marry
or wanting me to be thrown off a building
when I have a problem with you...and your
beliefs.
As for that leap of faith, I usually explain
my feelings about belief with a simple basketball
analogy.
If you told me you saw LeBron James dunk from
half court last night, well I couldn't take
that just on faith alone.
I'd need some sort of evidence, like at the
very leaast seeing the videotape with my own
eyes, as proof of your outrageous claim.
So it seems only logical to me to treat the
biggest questions of the universe with the
same intellectual rigor as my imaginary basketball
analogy.
Belief aside, there are many attachments people
have to religion which often are cultural
and based in tradition.
For me, being Jewish is a connection to the
history, an often painful history, of the
Jewish people, but also being aware of the
traditions, rich cultural heritage and historical
ties that I have to the people who came before
me.
While I'm not religious myself, it's the educational
emphasis of Judaism which let atheists like
Albert Einstein or Carl Sagan stay connected
to their cultural identity, without giving
up their commitment to logic and reason.
Without comparing myself intellectually to
anywhere near these two legends, it's this
type of understanding of Judaism I believe
in, but I have no desire to push this on you
or anyone else.
Joining me to discuss belief, religion, and
why Jews are funny is Rabbi David Wolpe of
Sinai Temple here in Los Angeles.
Rabbi Wolpe was named America's most influential
rabbi by Newsweek Magazine and one of the
50 most influential Jews by the Jerusalem
Post.
Where Larry David and Jesus half of Lenny
Kravitz fell on this list, we'll soon find
out...